uh hi i'm max kaiser this is the kaiser
report
well today we're going to talk about
what happens when
governments fuse together
with corporations what happens
stacy well it's certainly no country for
small
business remember that film no country
for old men
well we have become no country for small
businesses
as everybody knows like all the tech
giants have been raking it in during
this lockdown and covered pandemic
the small businesses were
allegedly there were some of these like
ppp loans that were meant for them
and most of it went to friends of the
big banks and
bigger clients of the big banks that got
all the free money that then
got discharged so i'm going to show you
a headline from the summer this was from
august and bloomberg
news and they said small businesses are
dying by the thousands and no one is
tracking the
carnage big companies are going bankrupt
at a record pace
but that's only part of the carnage by
some accounts small businesses are
disappearing by the thousands amid the
kova 19 pandemic
and the drag on the economy from these
failures could be
huge this wave of silent failures goes
uncounted in part because real-time data
on small business
is notoriously scarce and because owners
of small firms
often have no debt and thus no need for
bankruptcy
court yeah this is curious what sticks
out is that they're not tracking this
information so the small businesses are
the lifeblood of the economy it's like
saying
it's like saying the country decided not
to keep track of its children
right it's like saying we had 10 kids
but they wandered off one day
and we found out a year later that they
all died
but we don't care because um we
were busy um doing whatever it was
watching
netflix or something so it's interesting
especially now in an era of big data
and pervasive data and surveillance
capitalism
where these same companies that are
benefiting by the extermination of the
small firms
can tell you how many nose hairs you
have in your left nostril
at any given moment it can tell you what
your ear wax tastes like
jeff bezos has probably tasted more
earwax than any executive we know in
america today
because he's got a fetish he should know
that the small businesses that he's
putting out of business
will ultimately kill his customers but
wait
he doesn't care uh
yeah right and i guess that's kind of
old-fashioned in a way we haven't
emerged from the 19th century when
people
used to have 10-15 kids because half of
them would die from
all the diseases that we can now treat
so now we have to have 10 or 15
companies because
most of them are going to be killed off
by oligopolies or monopolies that
then use some of their ill-gotten gains
to finance political
that one of the two political parties
allowed and then
of course they get the laws passed to
put these people out of business
so while the businesses are small
individually the collective impact of
their failures could be substantial
firms with fewer than 500 employees
account for about 44
of all u.s economic activity according
to a u.s small business administration
report
and they employ almost half of all
american workers
again like everybody's on lockdown there
are rent and mortgage moratoriums now
being extended
to may 1st in some locations like in new
york city
aoc was just bragging how they've
extended the rent
so you don't have to pay your rent you
haven't had to pay your rent since march
in most places and now you don't have to
pay until may 1st
in manhattan but of course that means
like the
the person who owns the home or the
property isn't getting paid
as well but there's no compensation for
them so you see this playing out in the
number
so no no country for small businesses
here's from wolf richter
brick and mortar retail meltdown in
stunning manhattan style
years before and now during the pandemic
store rents had already plunged
amid surging vacancies then in spring
the market froze when it thawed
rents dropped to 10-year lows 13 charts
by quarter i'll just show you that
the area near trump tower so madison
avenue 57th street to 472nd street
and uh rents are down 54 so
you know manhattan's famous for shopping
right and it's because it doesn't have
those huge malls it's all like boutique
shops it's really interesting
locations but it's uh rents are
collapsing because the tenants are
moving out they're going bankrupt
right so i mean we've talked about this
in the past in terms of being
medievalism and
and we had the church at that time
who had a monopoly on heaven and would
hand out these people indulgences
for people who they deemed worthy
and nobody could argue with that or else
they would be
crucified and then we had the
enlightenment and we had
adam smith and we had free market
capitalism
and that was a short 200 year experiment
because now we're back to this medieval
model
where instead of papal indulgences from
the
pope we now have the money indulgences
printed
at the fed with the high priests like
aoc
and jerome powell and janet yellen so
we're back to medievalism and that's why
i think it's correct to
refer to the unwashed masses in america
and elsewhere around the world who are
participating in the global insurrection
against banker occupation
as peasants we have peasants
that would be billions of people around
the world and it would include about 200
million americans and that number is
growing almost
exponentially because the high priests
of the money printers believe
that you must pay homage to their
saintliness and godliness
or they won't give you any of their free
money oh it's so cozy
a lot of times when you put corporations
together
with government crypocracy
it takes other forms and
names like fascism
don't tell anybody it's fascist they'll
get really angry
uh corporatism and fascism yes indeed
well
i then have another headline about what
small business
is looking at going into this future of
is somebody has to pay right is jeff
bezos going to pay no
amazon's not going to pay they've never
paid taxes they don't pay taxes in
decades that's how
that's why jeff bezos is once again the
richest man in the world
uh elon musk is no longer richer than he
is
that's why these huge corporations
all the wall street banks they they pay
less than 10 in tax rates because of all
their write-offs they're able to
so somebody has to pay for all this free
money somebody has to pay for these rent
moratoriums
somebody has to pay for all this right
well
small businesses freaking out about
surging
taxes under biden so this is
a um a quarterly report that has been
going on since the 1970s it's the nfib
small business
optimism index and it slumped by 5.5
points to 95.9 so this is december's um
report and this is the first month since
donald trump
lost and decisively everybody knows he
lost
so uh their optimism slumped
uh to 95.9 falling below the average
index value
since 1973 of 98
a missing expectation of a triple digit
print
nine of the ten index components
declined and only one improved of no
owners expecting better business
conditions over the next six months
tumbled by a whopping 24 points to a net
negative
16 realizing that a democrat
administration is hardly conducive
to small business growth so they're
seeing these tech monopolies and giants
already occupy being named to uh
administrative uh
positions in the biden administration
they don't expect any help there but
they also
are expecting a huge tax increase and
that's the number one concern of small
businesses across america
right you know the way to overcome these
tax burdens and regulatory burdens would
be to start a business
work hard and become an independently
wealthy
individual in the land of the free home
of the brave
but we are talking about how the
rake of the majors like the amazons and
the googles
like they rake the bottom of the sea and
they get all that fish
they just rake all of the small
businesses
for anything they can and they leave
them for dead
on the roadside and thousands and tens
and thousands of them are dying
and this is predictable
because again if you put the money
printer in the hands of the worst
amongst
us you have a when in america anyway you
have a cachistocracy which is
ruled by the worst amongst us and we see
that all over the world as well not just
in the u.s
and you give them a money printer that
they can literally without restraint
by uh just print untold sums
then it's like imagine if charles
madison was running the
central bank and it was uninterrupted
for 20 years he was running the central
bank
then serial killing would be america's
number one
industry okay let's flash forward to
today we've got a central banker
who's serial killing small businesses
so the number one industry of america
today is small enterprise serial killing
what's the attitude of the people in
america well
when they can stop vomiting for five
minutes and look around
at their family that amer everyone
forgot about and they can't find the
kids anymore
they then decide well maybe it's time to
think about
some other country and that's i think
we've seen this before
usually you know people go on the move
the history of the world is migration
people are constantly moving to find
better land
better but been more hopeful except for
the fact that
okay if you get kicked off twitter if
you get kicked off facebook well
create your own app create your own
website except
aos aws and all the um
stripe the the financial services cut
you off and you can't do that
the same with america you could leave if
you want we're totally 100
free to leave if we want however however
i want to say however try to open a bank
account
yeah in in any country as an american
you can't
so therefore yes you can take bitcoin
with you
but you have to pay your utilities you
have to
pay you know you need a bank account for
a lot of the basics of life like
utilities internet
all that sort of stuff right i mean
bitcoin is the martin luther
of the medieval age by pounding those
dictates on the
you know the door of the vatican
essentially it's like all the papal
indulgences are done
we had the beginning of a ecclesiastical
revolution
right and that's what bitcoin is so as
dire as this all
sounds keep in mind that
it's the end of the road for the
monopolists and the gologopolis the
kakistocracists
well that's the point is that we are at
the end of the road of that
um because there's clearly
as you can see what has been happening
in america especially since 2008 2009
but around the world we have the giabo
that we have the global insurrection
against banker occupation that's an
international thing and what we've seen
is oligopolies and monopolies around the
world
have controlled a lot of the political
power a lot of the monetary power and a
lot of the wealth
and people are angry about it and that's
what you're starting to see here these
people are worried that
they know i mean it might not happen but
they're con they
see what's coming what's coming to them
and that all these programs need to be
paid for and they know that the
the elite don't pay for it the the mega
corporations that
you know hire these politicians aren't
going to pay for it so that they're
going to have to pay for it
it says this survey shows that only 2 of
them
are concerned about inflation of these
small businesses which is remarkable
because
obviously inflation is roaring towards
us so they're not even concerned about
that because they're more concerned
about the structure of our financial and
political economy
whereby the oligopolies rule and they
these small businesses
medium you know middle class people end
up paying
right do like tahini's restaurant in
canada put all your reserves into
bitcoin and you'll survive this blight
of neo-fascism here and around the world
all right don't go away we got more
you're coming your way
welcome back to the kaiser report i'm
max keiser time now to return to our
conversation with dave collum
chemistry professor who every year over
the past decade has been writing a
legendary year in review
column dave welcome back glad to be here
all right so your 2020 year in review is
called the year
everything changed eight and a half
trillion of treasuries are maturing by
the end of 2021.
voters want free money from biden it's
also the year
that the u.s dollar turns 50
will the dollar survive this year dave
well that's a that's got two layers to
the onion one is the dollar in the forex
market so i i never understand why the
dollar moves up and down relative to
other currencies
and i think i profoundly understand why
it moves down relative to
hard assets because they're constantly
working to destroy it so
so dollar on the forex markets i have no
idea what it's going to do but i it will
continue to
erode in terms of spending power yes big
time
right but back in 1971 u.s went off the
gold standard and it was the birth of
this all fiat world
and the dollar was king it looks like
it's losing its
traction in the global economy and other
countries are now doing bilateral deals
outside of the dollar
if the u.s dollar loses reserve currency
status
then we're going to see stuff in the
united states we haven't seen for a
while like real
inflation at the cpi level like prices
start to go up dramatically
and i think that's part of the mix so i
mean your overview seems to
paint a picture of uh not not a rosy
picture i would say
and isn't the dollar kind of losing that
status part of it dave
well i would think so um
i think you can see evidence of of of
consortia building in
faraway lands where they want to
possibly just so they're not dependent
on the dollar
create their own reserve currency so i
would imagine an alliance between russia
and china would be a massive play
and i think there's evidence of that
once they can say you know
you know they can flip off the dollar
then then the dollars
lost a lot of its kick and i don't blame
them for doing it either for that matter
right and uh so to us a push back to
this what we're hearing
uh about a new brenton woods or the
great
new resets coming in order to
quote build back better uh what do the
global central planners have in mind
with these phrases and ideas dave
well uh i don't know anyone who actually
knows the answer that question they're
big on platitudes and thin on details
um it appears as though it's a push
of the united states out of its sole
position as a superpower
it appears to be a push of the dollar
reserve currency out of the picture
uh i don't know what else it could be it
could they're going to roll a war on
cash into that story probably i'm
scheduled to speak with a currency
expert
one of these days we had to cancel and
uh and he thinks he knows so that'll
that tells me it's a currency thing
uh the world economic forum looks like
they're shooting for um
a global government to me global
government world economic forum or davos
and typically when these groups get
together and they
start to realign global forex markets
and
kind of rejigger the global economy gold
usually plays a part i think you might
even own a little gold dave
is is gold going to play a part in this
i would think gold would play a part um
probably gold will be underneath
everything for a very long time uh
you know the bigger debate is digital
currencies what they mean and you guys
know more about this than me
but uh i think the the hot debate is
whether
whether the the true cryptos will play a
role or become um
become at risk of having to do battle
with the sovereign states
i tend to fall in that camp so i think
that you guys who
have done fabulously well with bitcoin
at some point are gonna have to do
battle
against uh sovereigns that's my guess
whether you win or not
i don't know yeah i think it's an
interesting match-up
and what we're seeing is that more and
more uh various states various countries
instead of trying to fight bitcoin
they're adopting bitcoin and so this
ends up
creating a situation where countries are
going to be competing for bitcoin not
trying to quote
regulate bitcoin and that seems to be
built into the protocol as part of the
game theory
layer of it uh but as you point out it's
going to be
a battle royale for sure christine
lagarde has i think got
on her boxing gloves and she's ready to
enter the ring with bitcoin
i you know where my money is on that
dave now let's talk about civil unrest
uh we've been seeing over the whole of
2020.
how does that compare if at all to what
was seen in the late 60s and early 70s
in terms of the weather underground and
those sorts of groups
uh dave i don't want to you know say
that you're
of that age that you would know this
stuff personally but nevertheless
i am familiar with it yeah are we in the
same kind of weather underground
bombings going on on rest days dave
yeah except i worry they're more state
than they were in the 60s 60s looked
like an insurgency to me
the stuff i see now i doubt i doubt that
it's grassroots looks like astroturfing
to me
i'm getting at this point a little
paranoid actually i think i'm starting
to hear voices in my head
um but but i'm seeing things that are
happening all over the place that
that that i suspect have serious
serious backing to and i don't know what
it is and i don't know how to think
about it yet but i work hard at it
right you know uh stacey and i just
watched the documentary recently about
the
weather underground and it was a time in
the america where we had hundreds of
bombings from coast to coast
and domestic terrorism was almost
commonplace the cebanese liberation army
patty hearst was robbing banks
at the end of the vietnam war it was a
tumultuous period it was social unrest
it was richard nixon it was watergate it
was him resigning from the presidency
it was a really tumultuous time
how did how do we compare with that i
mean you mentioned more of some maybe
some foreign influence but
it seems how would you compare the two
to me
the current situation seems like a mild
re-run of that period dave
i would agree with that 100 actually and
and it might be the tip of the spear so
that when it's over we will not be
putting the word mild on it
um i do remind people who think you know
they say ah 2020 was awful i said you
know we're not
hiding in the london tube from the
luftwaffe right this is not the worst
year ever
uh and and and at the same time
um this this could be the beginning of
something very large and i'm
bothered by that and so i i just don't
know where it's going i'm just paying
close attention and and clueless i see a
cultural revolution equivalent taking
place
right now and and you can see it in all
facets of society
so so if we don't get a grip on
uh what what gave us the freedoms that
america is so famous for if we don't if
we don't remind ourselves of that we're
in serious trouble
you know you said something there dave i
got to pick up on a cultural revolution
uh brings images of mao china
and everyone wearing their mao outfit
and reading the little red book
uh now that you mention it i'm just free
associating here but now that you
mention it it seems like that is an
appropriate comparison it seems like
this new
regime coming into washington wants
everybody to look only at
certain pages of certain books at
certain times all descent is squashed
and you mentioned authoritarianism that
seems to be an element to it
is is this like a cultural revolution
type moment in america where we're all
going to
enter into a maoist type dictatorship
dave
yeah i mean it'll look different right
you know i i'm not going to use that try
phrase but
it'll look different but yeah it feels
like that to me um
they are attempting to rewrite in a race
history this is classic stuff
the uh the media is now 100 percent
propaganda
machine and so all the critical
ingredients
that that should be in place are in
place now and so
we're reaching a point now europe where
your political persuasion dictates
whether you get to have a voice
and and i viewed i've tweeted a couple
things on it where people got mad at me
but i said look you know
that the purge of social media the other
day was was sort of night of the long
nights it was a digital version
they're clobbering people off facebook
companies are now taking upon themselves
to
to defund the platform uh legitimate
concerns
because they want to take a stance
against free speech
parlors getting attacked um uh
uh a gab got attacked these are these
are
ominous ominous signs that that i don't
think
anyone would have considered possible
five years ago
right now you know the bigger question
is uh if we look at history and we see
cultures and economies collapse and
cultural revolutions occur
and pogroms existed and
we make comparisons to the united states
so
where is the seed the root cause of all
this to me
to kick this off i'll say it has to do
with that fiat money it has to do with
that money printing
where you've got mal investment and a
lot of people were able to buy their way
into washington
and we they they attracted what i guess
you could call a kakistocracy or
leadership by the worst amongst us so is
it that fiat money that's the base layer
of
problem here or am i missing something
well no i think that's part
of the story the other thing we did
there's an analogy i like to draw
between us and the saudis where
the saudi royals made this fundamental
mistake where they kind of
haphazardly handed over the school
systems to the to the
clerics and are then shocked 25 years
later to have a bunch of radical
hobbyists running around the country and
we we inadvertently handed over
um our educational system to the left
and at first
the the changes were not you say well
you know you teach the kids not to
discriminate stuff like that
but now it's gotten to a rather
indoctrination level and so now
uh some there's polls showing this i'm
like 35 or 40 percent of kids on college
campuses
think socialism is fine so they've
obviously thrown away the whole idea of
capitalism
and uh and and so i i
i think that it we've been rotting the
educational system
for several decades and so now you've
got the youthful generation who
who doesn't even know better and and
and that's what happens in in in
authoritarian regimes you just you lose
the
memory of what you were yeah that uh
saudi
handing the education system over to the
wahhabist i think there's a great
documentary adam curtis in the uk it's
called bitter lake
you might want to check that out but
anyway dave column
thanks so much for being on the kaiser
report
you're very welcome and thanks for
inviting me all right that's going to do
it for this edition of kaiser report
with me
max geyser and stacey herbert want to
thank our guest dave collum until next
time bye y'all
[Music]